hey what's going on ladies and gentlemen
just as a quick reminder I want to let
everybody know that I'm still going to
do that giveaway this weekend
all you guys got to do is subscribe to
this channel for your chance to win
these two prizes which is the Game of
Thrones t-shirt in this book and I'm
going to announce the winner in one of
my videos this weekend so I just want to
say good luck to everybody and I also
want to thank you guys a couple videos
ago actually started to ask you guys to
start liking the videos that way they
could reach a bigger audience and you
guys have showed up way more than I
could have ever expected I've gotten so
many likes on my last couple videos so I
actually want to do something if this
video gets more likes than my last video
which was probably like a thousand or
something like that I'm going to make a
big announcement this weekend right
after I give away these two prizes so if
you guys show up for me and give this
one more likes than the last I got
something you know in store for you guys
this weekend it's a pretty big surprise
I think you guys will really really
enjoy it but anyways let's get the video
started in today's video I want to talk
about Jorah Mormont and why I think he
will win in the game of Thrones but I
want to make something clear that
doesn't mean I'm saying he's going to
actually sit on the Iron Throne in this
video it's going to be the first video
of a series of videos I'm going to do in
which I think several characters are
going to win in a game of Thrones and
that doesn't just mean they're going to
survive until the end but not only will
they survive they're going to do it
successfully and I'm going to explain
exactly what I mean by that and in the
final video of this series I'm going to
make one about Cersei Lannister and how
she is losing the game of Thrones even
while she sits on the Iron Throne in
that last video we'll tie the entire
series together and make perfect sense
so I hope you guys will all come along
for the ride so let's begin and I want
to start off the video with being honest
with ourselves as of right now Joris
chances of surviving this game look
pretty slim and djor is actually lucky
to even be alive right now
because when the game of Thrones series
begun we learned that Jorah was actually
on the run because he had to flee
Westeros or else Ned Stark was going to
execute him and we all know that house
Mormont is a very old house and although
they were a pretty poor house there
one of the few houses that had ancestral
Valyrian steel sword which was a bastard
sword called Longclaw who is now owned
by Jon Snow
but that sword actually once belonged to
Jorah Mormont Jorah was once a respected
man when Lord Eddard Stark called for
his bannermen to help support him during
Robert's rebellion Jorah was there to
help and he fought at the Battle of the
Trident and during the great joy
rebellion and I think Jorah fought just
as good as anyone which did gain him
some fame not only in war but at the
tournay of Lannisport which was held to
celebrate the victory over the Iron
Islands and after Jorah one that
jousting tournament that's when he
crowned you know miss Hightower his
queen of love and beauty who he
eventually married but Jorah really
couldn't keep up with her demands and he
went broke trying to keep her happy so
that's when Jorah had the bright idea of
trying to sell poachers into slavery to
make some extra cash but after learning
that Ned Stark was coming to Bear Island
to pass on the Kings judgement for his
crime that's when Jorah and his wife
fled Westeros and went to lease where
juror became a sell sword but after six
months he ran out of money again and
that's when his wife ended up becoming a
concubine of a merchant Prince and Jorah
was exiled once again so the chances of
Jorah ever becoming an honorable man
again in Westeros are not looking good
at all
he's banished from his homeland his
family wants nothing to do with them his
wife left him and he's flat broke
so you fast forward a little bit and
that's when we see Jorah Mormont more
time with the Dothraki and Daenerys
Targaryen who was now trying to form an
army of her own so she can go home to
Westeros and retake the Iron Throne for
the Targaryen 's and luckily for Jorah
he could actually speak English so him
and Dany became friends pretty quickly
and he started to help advise her as she
was building her army and just when it
seemed like Jorah was starting to gain
some respect again he was banished once
again by Daenerys Targaryen for spying
on her for King Robert Baratheon at this
point Jorah was pretty much willing to
do just about anything to get back home
but he actually fell in love with Dany
during the process and he started to
begin to have faith in her mission so he
actually changed his mind
and decided that he was going to stick
this out and stay by her side but it was
actually too late and even though Danny
had love for him she could no longer
trust him and had to send him away so
once again it seemed like all hope was
lost for Jorah he had nothing and no one
to help him restore his name enough so
he could you know show his face again in
the north but luckily for Jorah once
again he spotted tyrion lanister at a
brothel
who was also one to run from Westeros
and that's when Geordi sided he was
going to take carrying prisoner and use
him as a hostage to try to get back into
Danny's good graces but on her way there
as if things couldn't get any worse for
Jorah they get attacked by stone men
while stealing through old Valyria and
after surviving the attack and landing
on shore Jorah realized that one of the
stone men actually touched him and he
now has greyscale which is basically a
death sentence so I think Jorah must be
thinking you've got to be effing kidding
me like yay this guy just can't catch a
break and even when he did he screwed it
up but the bad days aren't over just yet
because jours plan of getting back with
Dany
backfired when he presents her with
Tyrion Lannister she ends up sending him
packing again and not only that she
allows Tyrion to stay and join her team
Jorah was obviously devastated and also
heartbroken but he must know he's
getting pretty much exactly what he
deserved for betraying his queen so it
was back to the fighting pits
but luckily Dany attended one of those
tournaments in the entire arena comes
under attack by the last harpy who
starts slaughtering everyone as they
approach Dany in her counsel and right
when it appears that Daenerys is about
to be assassinated Jorah throws his
spear right past her head and kills the
would-be assassin saving her life and he
helps fend off the harpy long enough for
Danny to be flown to safety by drogon so
Daenerys now knows that Jorah does truly
love her and would do anything in his
power to protect her but he can't be
hanging around with this herpes outbreak
on his arm and that's when we get the
last scene between Jorah and Dany during
season 6 and that's when Danny commands
drawer to find a cure in return to her
immediately she
him to be with her when she takes the
Iron Throne and this is pretty much
music the drawers ears not only is he
back on good terms with the woman that
he loves in warships but he now has his
chance to return home even if not in the
north at first so jour is going to do
everything he can to find a cure and get
back to her but the future for Jorah is
still not looking very good he has no
lands no titles he doesn't even have a
place he can call home they've been
bouncing around so many times over the
past few years and now he has this
deadly infectious disease that seems to
be spreading more and more by the day
that will kill him if he doesn't do
something about it ASAP so the average
viewer would probably be wondering how
the hell do I see a good outcome for
Jorah in the seasons to come so let me
explain to you how he will rise once
again in for good this time
and how he will become a winner in this
game that he may not even be playing for
himself right now but I must warn you
guys I'm about to use some spoiler
photos from the set of season seven so
first things first Jorah will cure his
greyscale there are a few different ways
that he can do this but I think it will
more than likely happen in Oldtown with
the help of Sam and I know that would be
my first stop there are a shitload of
maesters there and a shitload of books
containing god knows what so I think if
he's going to be able to get the
information or knowledge to cure this it
would have to be at the Citadel and
after he gets the spread of his
greyscale to stop he will return to
Danny on Dragonstone photos from season
7 already show the two together and I
know he would not return to Dany without
curing himself first I don't think he's
ever going to disobey her again but
while he's at Dragonstone this is when
he's going to be introduced to Jon Snow
who is actually thought to be the son of
Ned Stark the same man that won a Jorah
dead and I think this is when George is
going to apologize to Jon for the crimes
that he committed in fleeing Ned's
punishment and they will also have a
discussion about Longclaw and jours
father who was John's former commander
and they might even talk about Lyanna
Mormont who is now the head of house
Mormont and jor-el he's going to talk
about how he disgraced a family and yada
yada yada and this is how George is
going to end up going north with John to
possibly capture a white to bring south
to prove to everyone of the threat and
John is going to tell Jorah that if he
helps him on this mission he will make
sure that he can have a talk with Lyanna
Mormont and if successful in his mission
the north can find it in their hearts to
welcome him back into the family
I don't think Jorah wants to die before
he can restore his relationship with his
family I don't think he wants to be
remembered as a man who ran from trouble
and I think this is going to be the
beginning of jours rise as a northern
hero so this is when we're going to see
John Jorah Gendry and Davos head north
for this mission but I think ginjury and
Davos are going to head to Winterfell
while Jorah and John head for the wall
whether or at least going to meet up
with torment in the helm and Thoris and
Bendrick her sorry Thoris and barrack
actually said barrack and Gendry in the
same thing for us and barrack may
actually tag along too but I haven't
seen photos of them in Belfast yet and
even though John may nearly be killed on
this mission he will make it out alive
and considering Jorah is going to risk
his life to help John I think he's going
to be granted permission to enter the
north again with no warrants for his
arrest and this is going to lead to a
sit down talk with Lyanna Mormont
and if you think Leona was a bit harsh
to the Lord's who wasn't there for John
during the Battle of the bastards wait
until she gets ahold of Jorah who made
her house look bad she's going to be a
one-man verbal assault unit unleashing
hell on Jorah who actually might break
down and cry but when she finds out all
that he has been through to get back and
that he personally risked his life on a
dangerous mission to help her King I
think she's going to forgive him and she
might not open the doors of house
Mormont for him but just not yet but
Jorah isn't finished he's not finished
yet no no no after all this Jorah will
go back south to fight
for Daenerys although we know he wants
to be home he is committed to Danny and
he's going to see this through to the
end but I got to be honest with you guys
I think Danny will die before the very
end of the show and I think she's going
to die in a way that Jorah will not be
able to prevent it and I think after
Danny dies that's when George going to
join house Mormont and fight for John
just like Davos did when stain has done
it I think Geor is also going to sit on
John's Council and Board of Advisors as
they prepare for one last war to save
mankind and I know something you
disagree with this but before the final
war takes place Jorah will own a
Valyrian steel sword again to take into
battle John may give him long claw back
and John will use Hart's Bane or Sam
could let Jorah use Hart's pain but also
have another theory how Jorah will get a
Valyrian steel sword but that i'm gonna
have to do that one in another video
because it's just too much to explain
right now but either way Jorah will have
a new sword for the war with the White
Walkers I guarantee it and fighting
alongside John they're gonna kick some
serious ass together let the bodies hit
the floor let the bodies hit the floor
sorry about that
Jorah along with some other main
characters which i will make a video for
in this series will then forever be
immortalized as the men who took down
the greatest threat civilization has
ever faced and in the end when the dust
settles in the smoke clears here we
stand like a mother [ __ ] gangsta and
that ladies and gentlemen is how you win
this game of Thrones that's right George
is going to fight side-by-side in the
very end with John and when they are
victorious Jorah will be known as a hero
back in the north again he is going to
restore his name and make everybody
proud of him again and that's how I see
his story ending I do not think George
is going to die not in a show so comment
below guys and tell me what you think
about the
where do you see his story going at the
very end of the show anyways thank you
guys for listening don't forget about
the giveaway and the big announcement if
this video gets a shitload of likes like
the other ones have thank you guys for
doing that for me
you guys always pull through in a big
way for me I always appreciate that and
I will see you guys in the next one bye